Hello, everyone, and welcome
to the content video going
over, well, it's going over a
lot. We're going to talk about
if statements, if else, and
if else, if else statements.
So these go along with control statements
in that they control
the flow of our code.
So I like the example it gives
here. Suppose that a passing grade
on an exam is 60. The pseudocode
would look like this. If a
student's grade is greater than
or equal to 60, display passed. So
what does that look like in code?
We would use an if statement.
And then we use the comparison
operators greater than, equal to,
less than, equal to, just
greater than, just less than, or
equal, equal to, to determine
truthfulness of statements.
And one thing that is really, really
important with if statements and
loops and a lot of other types of
things that you'll code, and this
is a syntax thing, is that when
you start an if statement, and some
of those other examples, you do
need to make sure that all the code
that comes after the colon with
it is indented properly. And we'll
do an example in just a minute so
you can see what that looks like.
But just know that if your indentation is
off, you're going to get a lot of errors.
This is kind of what an if
statement would look like with
a flow chart. So grade
greater than or equal to 60,
true, print passed, false, not
passed. So nothing happens.
Every expression could
be interpreted as either
true or false. This is an
interesting little tidbit.
Anything that's non-zero is
automatically interpreted
as true, but zero is
interpreted as false.
So that's a fun thing to
test out in your code.
And then the last thing we'll
talk about here before we jump
into some examples is the
fact that we don't use the
assignment operator when we're
using an if statement. We use
the double confusing, which is
called the equality operator.
So we use this to check
for something being equal
to something else instead
of a single equal sign
because that assigns a
value to another value.
So let's jump over to our code space, and
let's do a couple of
examples of if statements.
Okay.
So I could do something
like this. I could say, if 5
greater than 10, colon at
the end of my if statement,
print 5 is greater.
And then maybe let's code
another one down here.
we'll say if 10 greater
than 5 print 10 it whoops
10 is greater let's run
these and see what happens
okay so we only get one output that
says 10 is greater why do we only
get one output well as Python goes
through our code line by line, it
finds a false statement right here
on line five. So it says five greater
than 10. That is false. And so if it
comes back with a false statement,
any of the code that falls
under the if statement is not
executed. If it finds a true, it
will be executed. So that's why
we see this print statement that
is on line nine, because the
if statement on line eight
returned true. Now, what if I do
something like this? Let's reverse
the sign. If 5 less than 10.
And I run this code.
Okay, both of these statements
returned true, right?
5 is greater, 10 is greater,
but 5 is not greater than 10. So
what's the problem here? Well,
the problem is a hard-coded value.
And maybe that's not the best
idea. There's a lot of reasons why
it's not a good idea to hard
-code values and to use variables
instead. But we'll address that
a lot more as we go throughout
the course. So just know that if
you're going to do something like
this, it's probably best if you
maybe don't hard code values.
Let's do a couple more just
kind of simple examples that are
similar to if statements, but
a little bit different. So
I'm going to do just a couple
of little things in here. Let's
do 10 greater than or sorry
that's less than or equal to
5 print let's do 10
what did I do above that
greater than or equal to 5
10 equal to 5 and we'll do this is
the last one print 10 not equal to
five.
Okay,
you probably can determine
the truthfulness of each
of these statements before
I ever run the code, but
let's just kind of talk
through each one. So, ten
smaller than five, no, that's
false. Ten greater than five,
true. Ten less than or equal
to five, no, that's also still
false. Ten greater than or
equal to five, that'll be true.
Ten equal to five, no, but ten not
equal to five, yes. So, we should
see a variety of false true false
true false true and that's because
the way that our numbers are okay
so we could test for all of these
conditions in an if statement and
depending on if the statement came
back as true or false it would run
the code underneath the if statement
this is where that indentation
thing comes into play so anything
that is in my if statement even
if it had nothing to do with it um
it's a great day this would get run
within my in sorry this would get
run if my if statement returned
true so anything that's within the
scope of my if statement there okay
so then let's talk about if else
statements so let's say I have a
condition like a status actually let's
do a grade so grade let's say grade
equals 90 and we'll say if grade
how high do you need to get an A
Is it greater than or equal to 95?
So if grade is greater
than or equal to 95, then
we'll print out, you
have an A in the class.
Great work.
But realistically, there's a
lot of grades to check. And
we don't necessarily want to
say if grade greater than or
equal to, I don't know, what's
an A minus, an 89, I think.
Then we'll print out you have an
A minus in the class. Great work.
And we could go through and do this
for every single letter possibility
and that might be something that
we would want to do. But what we
could do instead is if we just wanted
to tell the student if they had
an A or not, we could say something
like this. If grade greater than
or equal to 95 print whatever and
then we can say else print you are
still learning a lot so if my if
statement does not return true by
default my else statement will
execute so if for whatever reason this
line or sorry this line does not
return true this line will always get
run so let's run this and you can
see that we are still learning a
lot. So let's change our grade up
here to 95 and we would expect to now
see you have an A in the class.
Great work. So that's kind of what
an else statement does. It runs
something underneath our if statement
if the if statement does not return
true. And then there is if elif,
which is a totally different
thing so let's take that grade
example again and let's say we've
got grade equals I don't know
let's say 76 that's a good grade
we could say if grade and this
is where I might get a little
bit long let me just kind of copy
this from a note that I've got
actually no I'll do the first
one so if grade and we already
said greater than or equal to 95
And
then what we did a second ago is we
said an else statement will execute
something else, but what if we
actually wanted it to run through every
single possibility before it ran an
else statement? We don't necessarily
want to code 19 different if
statements. And so what we could do is
we can use an else if. And so what
an else if will do is it will check
another condition. So I can say L if
grade greater than or equal to 90,
print,
and we already know, minus,
and then let's do another one.
L if grade, and this is where
I stop knowing what grades
equal which letters, so we're
just going to generalize. If grade
greater than or equal to 80,
let's just say you have a B,
we'll do L if grade greater than
or equal to 70, then you have a C.
And then let's throw an else on the end
of that, because if you don't have a C,
you probably have a not passing
grade. so we'll print you should go
get help you can totally do this
something like that so the thing
with an if l if statement is that
one condition only one condition
can be true all right so if I run
this it's kind of there's a lot in
my output let me comment this
stuff out let me run this again so
if I run my code, I should see the
letter C because I have a grade of
76, so I have a C, right? So if
I change this to a 90, I would
expect to see an A minus. If I
changed it to, I don't know, let's say
a 45% in the class, then I should
go get help and I can totally do
this, right? So only one of these
statements is ever true, but there
are times where you may still want
to use multiple if statements.
and that is when there can be more
than one true condition so maybe
if it's a Wednesday but it's also
the I don't know 20th of the month
those are two true conditions that
can both be become true so that's a
case where you might want to use
multiple if statements instead of an
if lf because remember with an if
lf there can only be one condition
that returns true so only one of
these statements will execute but
with you have multiple if statements
then it doesn't matter you can you
can have multiple if statements and
they are all testing for different
things. So that concludes this
content video. Thanks for watching.